So okay, ping is pretty simple, but
how do you think traceroute works?
I'm not going to make this a quiz
because it really is pretty tricky.
The ability to trace out packet paths
wasn't intentionally built into
the Internet protocols.
Rather, a clever engineer named
Van Jacobson discovered that a safety
feature that was made to prevent
infinite loops made it possible to do
traceroute as well.
Here's the safety feature
traceroute makes use of.
Every packet has a time to live or
TTL field, which starts at
some large number and is reduced by one
each time that packet hits a router.
As it moves through the network,
each router reduces the TTL on
the packet by one as it passes it on,
all the way until it finally
gets to its destination.
This means that if routers
are misconfigured so
that packets flow around in an infinite
loop, eventually the time to live
on each packet will drop to zero,
and it will expire.
This helps keep momentary loops from
crashing large parts of the network with
an overload of traffic.
When a packet's TTL expires,
the router that last received it,
sends a tiny error message back
to the packet's original sender.
And that message says that
the packet's TTL expired, and
it gives the address of the router
that saw that packet die.
So given that idea, now can you
think of how traceroute might work?
The TTL mechanism means that if
a program sends a packet with TTL0,
it will be immediately killed, and
an error message will come back.
If it sends a packet with TTL1, it'll
go one hop, land on the first router,
get decremented to 0, killed,
and an error will come back.
Then with TTL2, it'll go two hops to
the destination before it gets killed.
So sending packets to a destination with
progressively increasing TTLs starting
at one, the traceroute program
gets an error message back
from each router on the way
to that destination.
And it can use those error messages
to reconstruct the path which is
just the list of those routers
in order that a packet takes to
get to that destination.